it's just about not losing vision and
not losing sight of what you're what
you're trying to accomplish no matter
what hurdles you have to go through high
school prospect I had nobody really
running knocking on my door saying
please please please come play for our
school I'm prepared well to this summer
to continue to get better and learn from
those mistakes Hong Kong I want to be
great in US I want to be the best player
in the league got to be creative cuz I
can't dump like I've always said
offseason the way for us to get there is
to stay in the moment Hughes want to be
the hardest-working guy no matter what
you do in life when things are going
well they're not you still have to have
that upbeat kind of personality in it it
gets guys going just be the best version
of yourself and anything that you do
Stephan's explosiveness ness lettuce
isn't our below standard he's an
American NBA player for the Golden State
Warriors he holds the record for the
most consecutive games played with a
three-pointer made he is considered by
many to be the greatest shooter in NBA
history
he's Steph Curry and here are his top
ten rules for success
well from being in the visualize where
you want to be and what you want to
accomplish and you kind of get lost in
the process of day-to-day you know
grinding it out and working pulling on
ours if you have to you know that this
is just about not losing vision and not
losing sight of what you're what you're
trying to accomplish no matter what
hurdles you have to go through so I
think that kind of relates to whatever
you're doing whatever you know major
you've chosen what you're interested in
so for me in basketball and it's about
you know visualizing whether you write
it down put it on the wall do something
with what your goals are and get lost in
the process of the day-to-day grind
day-to-day getting better every single
day asking questions aligning yourself
with people that have been through it
before that that are experienced and
leaning on that advice and just trying
to outwork the next person and
today's thing occurring of the steel
Finch player City God right now for the
lawyers you think there were no hurdles
or obstacles that I had overcome but
even I got to high school I wasn't
ranked that's um you know I wasn't
ranked I wasn't highly touted as a high
school prospect I had nobody really
running knocking on my door saying
please please please come play for our
school until coach McKillop called and
you know everything happens for a reason
and there's there's a story in to to
everything and and if you take time to
realize you know what what your dream is
and what you really want in life no
matter what it is whether it's sports
whether it's in other fields you have to
realize that there's always work to do
and you want to be the hardest working
person in whatever you do and you'll put
yourself in position to be successful
and you have to have a passion about
what you do and basketball was mine and
that's what scared me to this point
puts his foot on the pedal place it in
with
what teams obviously try to stop you
that's the way to stop the Warriors cut
the head off the snake
the five of you at times last year in
the playoffs what have you learned from
that experience not uh those times of
temporary you know just keep my
confidence keep my aggressiveness
I've prepared well to this summer to
continue to get better and learn from
those mistakes alcohol we're going to
happen there's no avoiding that but just
making sure that it doesn't kill your
calm
doesn't change the way you're playing
you have to be obviously get smarter
kind of figure it out and then maybe
find all the ways to impact the game
whether it's on the defensive end did it
stop seeing Steve of pushing the tempo I
always need to be making shots to
hopefully impact the game so got to
figure that up sorry all pretty psychic
close up there is the first girl
doozie transfer
beautiful bubai
see you have the best handle in the
league right now I want to be great in
us I want to be the best player in the
league and I won not work you know to
accomplish that goal and what not so I
don't know what it takes to make that a
definitive answer and I come out every
night with the same mindset and
obviously LeBron is a world-class
athlete been doing it for double-digit
years in the league and playing a you
know incredible high level so there's a
sense of longevity there just a sheer
talent that you know he brings but I'm
trying to do it my way and and help my
team can until you get wins and continue
to elevate our our our status to know
whatever you want to call it but that
that team that everybody knows about
this that comes out ready to play and if
I do my job then things will take care
of themselves
as curries 3 gives the Warriors the lead
one thing we've seen a ton of this year
almost every game a super high off the
glass floater you're shooting like 70%
in the restricted area is that the Steve
Nash influence in Hawks I see a lot of
that in you the way he used to shoot
one-handed off the dribble and just put
it super high off the glass something
you're doing a ton this year
you got to be greater because I can't
don't I don't know I just saw you throw
it on a lefty right after the shooter ah
yeah I need a low value with a five-step
gather but I gotta be great to try to
get the ball in the glass get it in I'm
in the paint so that creativity is I
watched guys like Steve like my teammate
Landrieu our boat so guys that are
really clever around the basket without
you know being above the rim kind of guy
so I've taken a lot from them and just
you got to be creative
well he makes it look so easy we talked
a lot at the start of the season about
the bowl 72 and 10 record and of course
we don't want to talk about it then is
it something that you're ready to kind
of focus on now it's still tough I mean
we know the opportunity is there it's
becoming more realistic for us to to
talk about it and to see where we are
but like I've always said all season the
way for us to get there is to stay in
the moment I know I don't know what
Jordan and the Bulls with their their
mark was I don't know who they surpass
innate and they won 72 games but what
coach Kerr says they stayed in the
moment and just focused on here and now
and looked up at the end of the season
maybe the last two or three games had a
chance to you know keep pushing that
record so we have to follow that kind of
that kind of game plan
not fast forward to April it's going to
come it's going to be it's going to
happen but stay in the moment do what we
do every single night and we have an
opportunity down the stretch at the last
week or so the seasons go get it because
who knows how many times we'll have an
opportunity to be in this position
can't duplicate this in horse to the
spinning music
want to be the hardest-working guy no
matter what you do in life really that
was the best advice he gave me we're all
talented in some way shape or form and
you have a passion so once you find out
what that is
I'm just exhausted all efforts to better
yourself every day in that regard so
when I was in eighth grade I knew
basketball was mine
and want to do whatever it took to be
successful so that's kind of
the mission from from early childhood
just thankfully I was able to find out
what my passion was an early age and
stickers
he also had a mentality shift back in
2011 I know you spent the day with
Carolina Panthers football team spent
some time in meetings with Cam Newton
how did that affect the way you view the
game you know he had that light hearted
kind of vibe about him that hey we're
out here we're serious we're focus were
competitive but we can do it in a fun
way and smile and laugh and enjoy
ourselves while we do it so I have a
very similar vibe on the on the floor
where the things are going whether not
you still have to have that upbeat kind
of personality that it gets guys going
want to see a doable move watch this one
double behind your back lock it down and
the bench is loved it talked about faith
passion obviously the drive with the
guys that I've been around and guys that
surround me every single day but a part
of that is having the will to succeed
you knowing that you put the work in and
have the confidence to let it show what
I tell people is just be the best
version of yourself and anything that
you do you don't have to live anybody
else's story sometimes people make it
seem like you have to have certain
prerequisites or a crazy life story in
order to be successful in this world but
the truth is you really don't it doesn't
matter where you come from what you have
or don't have what you lack what you
have too much of but all you need to
have is faith in God an undying passion
for what you do what you choose to do in
this life and a relentless drive and the
will to do whatever it takes to be
successful and whatever you put your
mind to make sure you live in the moment
and work your butt off every single day
and I hope I inspire people all around
the world to just be themselves be
humble and be grateful for all the
blessings in your life
the tightest and her he's got it
and
and curry delivers I'll pick one the
force overtime
Steph Curry with shot.0 joining Stefan
curry 6-3 185 pounds position point
guard Stefan's explosiveness and
athleticism our below standard he's not
a great finish around the basket
he needs to considerably improve as a
ball him often struggles against
physical defenders Stefan must develop
as a point guard in order to make it and
lead you have limited success at the
next level do not rely on him to run
your team my expedited mo words courage
what's the deepest behind
fires a tray
shuri thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because angel Diaz asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which is Steph
Curry's top ten rules meant the most to
you leave it in the comments I'll join
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon